so it's a this talk is crafted in a way
so that both coding and killing
theorists or none of the above can
understand it so bear with me so in
cloud storage what we want is that our
content be reliably student and they
also want very quickly accessible we
don't want it to sit somewhere and be
completely forgotten for centuries and
that requires energy and lately it has
been shown that coding minimizes
resources needed to maintain the
guaranteed reliability of the storage
and so what they want to look into is
what codes can do for accessibility or
what those which are already implemented
are for our reliability are doing to
accessibility and if this node fails
what we want to do and what has been
said before here in this workshop is to
still able to recover data reliably for
the remaining storage and we also want
to be able to reproduce what is lost
with the minimum are download from the
remaining storage or by accessing some
very small number of nodes and that has
generated very many very interesting
problems in coding theory and we just
talked about one such approach so what I
want to look into is do new codes for
distributed storage affect data
retrieval and there are two parts to
this talk so the first man is looking
into something like this suppose you
have this code which is a B and a plus B
so there is this redundancy here which
is only saying that any two of these are
sufficient for recovery a and B this is
sort of like about the butterfly example
for this limited storage a request comes
and suppose suppose if a plus B and B
are the first man to be fetched you're
in business
but now you have some arrival model to
these to the system and this is
something the time going to model by
using some queueing theory here so its
first walk into a single ml 1 q so there
you have request which arrived at rate
lambda according to samples on process
and drop service times of exponential
distribution of retinue many matrix of
interests are very well understood for
this model in particular that the
response time from the moment you
arrived at the moment you're out of of
the system is also exponential in the
rate is mu minus lambda there is another
queuing model which I am going to need
and this is called the fork join and
Sarah Burke you model the request
arrived at rate lambda again according
to a Poisson process but they're split
on that item and have to be joined at
the departure so very often are some
kind of a how to say that a supermarket
model is used suppose for people from
the same family arrive to the
supermarket each mother Goose buy milk
father bread kids candy or something but
they all have to go back to the same car
and it's seen as a key model for
parallel distributed computing like raid
so it was a very it was introduced I
don't know 70s 80s and now it's becoming
again a more of interest because of my
produced and few analytical results
exist but various approximations for
better now so but we are going to
introduce a gadget which is similar to
that it's just we are going to call it
NK for observing system not n n because
not everything has to join it a
departure because we have coding right
so architecture is Fe spirit I'm
deliberately going to use to avoid using
MDS or some kind of our terminology
because there are people in the audience
were not familiar with that but F is
split into K blocks and encoded into and
block so that any k out of end blocks
are sufficient for content
reconstruction and there are encoded
blocks that are
done and different disks or service and
in operation users request a forked into
own and disks and download from any key
jointly enables reconstruction of s so
this was that the architecture that that
event over is an example but this is
what what how the operation looks like
so so now this is a replicated request
to all of them and what happens is that
for the first job 1 and 1 are already
served two is served out of the green
jobs so when we served another is still
waiting another is still waiting but
it's something abandoned now maybe the
three here is already being sir so there
is lots of dependent series is something
and that's why it's so hard to analyze
so what I need for us not being a
queuing person I said let me do before
students come for their internships let
me do some simulations and see what's
going on here and I took a 10k for
joining model in which there are 10
queues and then I i can either
completely replicate everything so
everything can be downloaded from any of
the service of disks so there I have k
is equal one and then rk5 and k 10 this
is for join and this is simple
application it turns out that these
curves these are histograms and these
are envelopes that take somehow cross
but if you look at these are these are
PDFs of the download time but if you ask
something which usually is asked in
practice and that is how many people are
going to be able to download their
content in so much time then you are
talking about CDF right and it looks
something like this and this is sort of
this this is aa blown up this little
part over here and let me again say what
I'm plotting so I'm also here concerned
with resources so if i have a
replication system and i can download
from any on the disks that means the
my content has to be available my file
has to be available everywhere so my
storage goes tenfold but I can also only
double a storage store of one-fifth of
the original file on each of the disks
this is I'm keeping denim or i can keep
the same storage just split far the file
into 10 pieces and and this is sort of
then I can download this in parallel it
is interesting here that something which
requires tenfold increase in storage to
achieve certain performance is not
really much for us then something which
requires only doubling in storage and in
fact if I'm willing to sacrifice if I'm
willing to say no one will be really
able to but if you will be able to
download their content very fast I
actually am even doing better because
very many of them will be idle to
download a short period of time yeah and
this black here is if I don't have if I
just have a single if I didn't replicate
so this is the black line here that I'm
I'm doing much better there is another
thing that I can do instead of saying
instead of saying I'm giving you 10
discs and you know you let's see what
happens if you double or 10 topple your
storage I can also say for each file I'm
willing to give twice the storage of the
file is class and it's my problem how I
distributed over different disks so I
can put it on to or I can put it on on
for half each or I can put it on 10 150
and their this curves don't cross any
more because what's happening here is
I'm just getting what information
theories like to call diversity more and
more diversity and therefore it's better
to spread everything around all right if
you want to analyze that what happens k
and means no redundancy that is the
photo in queue k 1 mins replication and
it can be looked into as an independent
I mean values or also can be looked into
as a single mm QB the service rate and
you ought and everything in between
means no independence that means coding
so again information according to Eunice
like to call this replication and this
redundancy like redundant isn't accept
or more sophisticated at replication in
other areas i realized that the
redundancy is just also applications so
we are interested to just in the mean
response time in this stock previous
work has attempted attempted finding
this for for joint view but only bounce
alone and in fact there is only closed
form only for the expected value when n
is equal to two and everything is
exponential so everything is anyone so
it Centauri ously hard the effective
either so let's see the n1 for joining
you say I've had elastic a very nice
stock by by a professor from CMU more
hardcore pastor who is queuing theory so
the end point for joint q is actually
something which is very easy to analyze
and it boils down to having a single
queue with the service area NMU that's
one way to look into it if you do some
reasoning or you can even look at it as
as this timing out processes as a person
splitter so so you're you're my other
your arrival rate goes down and fold
what what the this group from CMU are
did is they actually have complete an
alibi or complete analysis for in one
case is not hard but what they're doing
is this stuff is this okay yeah we had
various accidents previous they see it
so suppose that here is my fork and I
only need one going out so what they
have it's reducing your symbols for this
problem so so what they have different
NL so they could have something smaller
may be different and again when going
out some of the service overlapping
or they may even have a single man so
and can be even one so even for this it
turns out although although these guys
are saying it took them a year to find
the solution it exists in the closed
form so that's the first exact analysis
other than that on these sorts of
problems there are many people in the
audience who've read canal and his group
neha Rashmi can go it's becoming develop
some papers at ITA so it seems to be
coming interest of interest in our
community um as well as networking human
border alright so um what we can do is
derived ounce on these and let me just
say how the upper bound is is is derived
and then I want to move to another topic
so suppose I have ten siblings and I
arrive to a supermarket and then emre
comes with ostensibly siblings or with
his ninety resultant of us and 10 of
them and I am in front of embree and i
need five of us to finish and suppose
for already finished i am going to stop
Emrys guys who are behind me from
advancing until the fifth one finishes
that way i am kind of introducing
independents removing the dependence in
other way and that is also writes that
an upper bound so since i'm stopping
something over there I'm I should be
able to do at least as good as that if
not better so this is the principle so
now our with that you can by using cater
the statistics of the exponential
distribution since I know these are mmm
bands I can find expected time and
variance and use a queuing theory
formula to to find an expression for the
serving time which is an upper bound
there is a completely different
reasoning for the lower bound which I'm
not going to get into ah but but would
like to to point something else here and
this is the following we decided at some
point to ask the following question we
said you know ah there is this work by
the that is called power of 2 by
Commissioner halves I think even PhD
thesis but again in the supermarket you
arrive and instead of joining the
shortest line you for which to know that
it shows this you would have to check
many lines and say this one is the
shortest I don't to go there you take
two at random and choose the shorter of
those two and it looks like that
actually you you get almost everything
you get lots of gain by looking into two
as opposed to looking into none and all
other improvements that are not that big
if your self looking now in two three
and so on so we said this is called the
power of two choices and we said how
about the power of choosing all and to
in order to be able to compare with that
since we're talking about storage I have
to have my content everywhere so in
order to implement this power of 2
scheme I have to have content everywhere
that will allow me to and so that's
already a tenfold storage so the if it's
10 if the number is 10 then I have to
compare the only possible comparison is
210 run and not ten some other k because
then the storage is not it's not the
same and in general we'll come back to
that it's hard to put this thing these
different systems in the common
denominator and make a fair comparison
but all I can do 20 out of two so there
I am doubling the storage but I'm taking
two out of 20 sorry I'm again making
storage ten times larger but I'm taking
two of the 20 and of course the more I
spread the better it is so so this is
the results for our 12 21 out of 10 and
these are the power of of the choices or
deletion request
this is how it compares with some other
power ok so now what is a good model for
the service time so this I want to talk
about because there may be some coding
problems Larkin into this bin within
this question suppose I have this this
people over here waiting to be served
and different cashiers so that they have
different devices here their cash is so
different this guy even has the the
portable one and they all split our and
I need one or two are to finish to be in
business so even though I suppose I'm
destroyed a reading here even though I
am I have the same kind of picture in
front of me because this guy said maybe
doing something else it means something
someone may come and ask for a price
check or they may run out of I don't
know paper bags or whatever that is
still I'm told or that it's a good
assumption thought to say that these are
independent but suppose that they are
not and suppose that is the sleeping guy
is always in front of me is there some
kind of a coating solution which will
prevent further so the first thing that
comes to my mind is is something like
the combinatorial designs saying that if
this sleeping guy is here in this row in
front of me I should make as my
scheduling according to some
combinatorial design which is going to
prevent him to block me in any other q
so that's what may be coding way coming
and now I'm going to get into a little
bit different problem which talks about
this course with local repair and
availability are there any questions
here
if not I just move on that is a break
after the second tuk so our coats with
rt availability again many in the
audience night but many don't sell just
bear with me that'll I go with them so
are there RT disjoint repair groups for
each data symbol in this codes so if i
have my data I have my redundancy maybe
that somehow there is a systemic part in
the redundant part and when the systemic
one of the systemic bits is our symbols
is destroyed that are raised to repair
it from small groups and independent
nother or none other laughing of other
symbols to do that we have heard these
beautiful talks are during the this week
and earlier in this program there are
various beautiful constructions there is
something different this are sorry there
is some penalty that you have to pay in
the code performance in the minimum
distance if you want to do that here is
an example so again for people who don't
know coding suppose I have these three
numbers and they have this other
additional three equations so if I want
to recover f1 i can even not recover but
let's say access if one i can either ask
everyone directly or if this server is
busy I can ask I think Alex throw some
kind of a cartoon characters but he gave
this talk I can ask the black group f2f1
+ f2 these are two equations with two
unknowns which I can solve right or I
can ask the blue group f3 + f1 + f3
these are again two equations with two
unknowns that that I can solve so the
repair groups are this this there is a
systemic evolution f1 in to repair
groups this index 1 the first group and
the other in this is just affairs that
is the first symbol our van is to it and
for a second and fourth and the third
one is second one is the tree and the
last 26
okay so now this is a the most recent
records they'll just a part of it so
suppose I have that code and I want to
request f1 so now I want to introduce
some dynamics here and this is the
following a request of f1 is mapped is
replicated now I'm replicating my
request in 2 3 1 i'm going to ask this
at the same time i'm going to ask the
black blue group and the blue group but
now each one of these is a complete for
join so it's happening to analyze so not
I serves its task in x SI this is my
this is my assumption and we assumed
exponential but the topology of this is
kind of is not easy so before I go to
that let me just recap again what I'm
doing here so what we tree was talking
about is so this is an episode in a Hong
Kong mole so there are you know if you
ever enter apple store there are iPads
in radio stations right not and and
there is this cleanup going on inside
but it's caught by coding theorists in a
very nice kind of algebraic environment
and there is this more about their which
is going to now be accessing this and so
now the question is what really happens
can be somehow analyze what happens
there so do availability coats really
make the stored data available this
would be a queuing model which again has
a very tough topology you have you can
request here or you can have this
several independent for coins but what
we are going to do is instead of that do
something different let's say that the
requests are going to be served not with
the queue but again at some random time
again when the request can be served i
can assume that it's random for various
reasons that i mentioned but let's say
that that that it's a slow some kind of
a slow arrival model so i don't worry
about that either let me see if i can at
least say something about that so
secondly as soon as I come I can be
served but it will take the server some
exponential time some random time which
is exponentially distributed to get me
what I want and that like that can be
done by from the front of res principles
i can compute certain things so so it's
interesting for example that that for
that particular model now i am not
accessing the entire file but just the
first symbol that the new ride out so so
so what is going to be at the minimum of
these and any of these but any of these
is a maximum of the service time because
they have to download all still I can
write that from the from the first
principles and compute and it turns out
to be a function with the name so that
is kind of curious i may be kind of
happy that something we took kind of
complex see i can analyze it from first
principles but does it sound to anything
well it's some sort of a bit a function
by the name so so you can see here
there's actually advance your your tea
is large increasing with a little bit
doesn't help much so it has kind of
diminishing returns because if you look
at the derivatives of beta function and
so on what about MDS codes so these are
the codes again that k any of any k
after then are good so here again i can
do various different scheduling policies
but i'm going to schedule my request in
the following way i'm going to ask this
one and I'm going to ask all of these
but as soon as i receive any k of this
i'm done whatever come first this one or
any k out of this in fact as soon as i
receive this i don't care what's
happening here anymore when i compute
these again aa again it somehow starts
complex then it gets into beta function
but when you some everything it just
turns out to be k again for the MDS code
now you also can compare italy that what
we call repetition code this is the SEC
dundon see businesses basically
replication right if I want to compare
our code which has availability t.v the
replication
I have to replicate the T plus 1 times y
because they have a systematic entity
repair groups so in replication I need
to have T plus 1 I have the rapidity
plus 1 times now again I am NOT doing
I'm just doing all the statistics of t
plus 1 Exponential's and therefore are
that the minimum orders that minimum of
the Exponential's is again exponential
with T plus 1 so it's time time's your
service time so so now if I normalize
that so that the cumulative service time
in the replication system is the same as
in the MDS code I get the same result so
for the replication if I normalize it
that way so so now the question is
really what should we normalize it's
when we compared on the physical layer
coating systems we usually normalize it
to have the same eb over n0 so and for
that is and then we say all right that's
how we compare them fairly but here
there are very many moving parts so what
should we put them together so so anyway
this is a table 3015 MDS code so how do
we compare them this is just a
replication if I have bit 1515 what they
call the information bits and altogether
authorities of my redundancies is 15
here and replication I have to replicate
it t plus 1 times and these are total
two codes one is by angkat who who's one
of the first who started looking into
this and the other is by sake here I
don't know which one is yours may be the
first for the second one is the from
your paper anyway I wrote them in the on
purpose like this so so the emptiness
and replication they were going to two
you will be able to do it in half the
time on average then if you didn't have
any redundancy but if you use one of
these coats with I availability it's
kind of two thirds so so these in that
sense provide mode but then then again
you know this is a thought tolerance is
different than what not oh you're using
about several serve various other so
enough they don't seem to be clear
winners or development coding systems in
this particular instance where you are
asking for only one not not for all of
them we do have so this is just the
analysis when we don't have queuing we
just have everything independent we do
have some results on queuing and some
kind of first results of what we could
say how code should be are a design
maybe not the way we are exactly doing
now but a little bit differently we
should enable some of these things to
visually label wants to say that yes
coats with availability indeed make the
store data more available so talking
about availability without taking
traffic into requirement is like talking
about codes in the physically a bit of
taking the snr changes in the
requirement and of course you know
repetition code is the best there is no
penalty to pay that's all i have to say
equation Serena
maybe I hadn't quite instance are you
saying that instead of asking the
different nds oh you only need k you
should ask for many more but you know
how in the system is the extra request
they load the system or they just you
know either just in some wait mode and
and their don't really know this so
that's an excellent question and we are
kind of trying to guess and I'm trying
to talk with people who know in that you
know I used to talk about with circuit
designers when i was doing code sort of
the physical layers and it's interesting
you're kind of afraid yeah you're afraid
of something and they just tell you
don't worry that doesn't cost anything
and then you're afraid you're not afraid
of something and then they say like in
my family i'm sort of a dirty engineer
everyone else is a doctor so I come
there with the knee bleeding and they
say look I'm going to dice in there ah
that's nothing but this thing over here
which you don't even see is something
that they're really worried about so so
I don't yeah I I don't really have a
definite answer to this question but
I've been seriously trying to talk
that's why I went here last week to
Moore's paper there is a run around Iraq
writer hear from our department who may
be able to answer the question better
than I can but yes we are now looking
into costs
okay any other questions if not we'll
have now a pretty mini break and when we
come back we still have three blocks but
the afternoon is free really can I just
yes I now